[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: So our guests today
are Neal Stephenson and Nicole
Galland, and they've
written a book called
"The Rise and Fall of D.O.D.O."
You may know them from their
other books, which I will not
attempt to list from memory,
but you can look those up.
So Neal and Nicole,
take it away.
NEAL STEPHENSON: [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
So we have a little program that
goes for 20, 25 minutes, where
we're basically just reading
some segments from the book,
from the early part of the
book, that kind of set up
the storyline a little bit
without being too spoilery.
And so Nikki is going to begin
by reading just the opening
few pages, and then
I'll do a little bridge,
and we'll jump ahead
about 30 pages.
NICOLE GALLAND: Cool.
All right.
"Diachronial--
preamble, July, 1851.
My name is Melisande Stokes,
and this is my story.
I am writing in July,
1851, common era or--
let's face it-- anno
domini in the guest chamber
of a middle class home in
Kensington London, England.
But I am not a native
of this place or time.
In fact, I am quite
desperate to get out of here.
But you already knew
that, because when
I'm done writing
this thing, which
for reasons that will
soon become clear
I'm calling
diachronical, I'm going
to take it to the very discreet
private offices of the Fugger
Bank, Threadneedle Street, lock
it up in a safe deposit box,
and hand it over to the most
powerful banker in London, who
is going to seal it
in a vault, not to be
opened for more than 160 years.
The Fuggers, above all
people in this world,
understand the dangers
of diachronic shear.
They know that to open the box
and read the documents sooner
would be to trigger
a catastrophe that
would wipe London's financial
district off the map
and leave a smoking
crater in its place.
Actually, it would be much
worse than a smoking crater,
but a smoking crater is how
history would describe it
once the surviving witnesses had
been sent off to the madhouse.
I'm writing with a steel-nibbed
dip pen, model number 137B,
from Hughes and Son,
Ltd. of Birmingham.
I requested the extra fine tip,
partly to save money on paper,
and partly so that I
could jab my thumb with it
and draw blood.
The brown smear across
the top of this page
can be tested in any
21st century DNA lab.
Compare the results to what is
on file in my personnel record
at D.O.D.O.
headquarters, and you
will know that I am a
woman of your era writing
in the middle of
the 19th century.
I intend to write
everything that
explains how I came
to be here, no matter
how far-fetched or
hallucinatory it may sound.
To quote Peter Gabriel,
a singer-songwriter who
will be born 99 years from
now, this will be my testimony.
I do attest that I am
here against my will,
having been sent here
from September 8th, 1850,
and from the city of San
Francisco, California the day
before California was
granted statehood.
I do attest that I belong
in Boston, Massachusetts
in the first quarter
of the 21st century.
There and then, I am
part of the Department
of Diachronic Operations, a
black budget arm of the United
States government that has
gone rather badly off the rails
due to internal treachery.
In the time in which I write
this, 1851, magic is waning.
The research that D.O.D.O.
Paid me to perform
indicates that magic
will cease to exist
at the end of this
month, July 28th.
When that happens, I
will be trapped here
in a post-magic world
for the rest of my days.
The only way anyone
will ever know
what became of me is
through this deposition.
While I have managed
to land myself
in comfortable, by 1851
standards, quarters with access
to pen, ink, leisure
time, and privacy,
it has been at the
expense of freedom.
My hosts would not
consider allowing me out
of the house alone for an
evening constitutional,
let alone to seek out
witches who might help me.
One comment before I begin--
if anyone from
D.O.D.O. Ever reads
this, for the love of God,
please add corset makers
to the list of abetters
we need to recruit
in any Victorian DTAPS.
Corsets are intended
to be custom
made to conform to the actual
shape of a lady's body,
and it's uncomfortable to
have to borrow one or buy one
off the rack, although servants
and poorer women generally do
that, but do not
lace them tightly,
as they must engage
in manual labor.
Being here entirely
on charity, I
prefer not to ask my hosts to
extend credit for a custom fit
one, but wearing this one
borrowed from my hostess
is just awful.
It makes a Renaissance
bodice feel like a bikini.
I'm not even kidding."
NEAL STEPHENSON:
So she goes on--
Mel, Melisande--
goes on to explain
how she was working at Harvard
University in the Department
of Ancient Classical Languages
as a downtrodden and exploited
adjunct faculty member when she
met a young man named Tristan,
who was clearly not from
around there in the sense
that he was a kind of
military ROTC-ish kind of guy.
And Tristan recruited her for
a top secret government job
with an entity known as
D.O.D.O., which he would not--
he doesn't explain what the
initials stand for at first,
so she has to keep guessing
what it might mean.
And the job has to
do with translating
a trove of miscellaneous
ancient documents
that D.O.D.O. has come
into the possession of,
and it all has to
be done secretly.
So they get a space in a
building between Harvard
and MIT that's kind of
a classic start-up den,
just a crappy old
building, where
little companies go in and
out of existence all the time.
And they have a
space there, and they
fill it up with these documents
and start working on them.
And it becomes clear that every
single one of these documents
has something or other to do
with magic as a real thing that
once existed but exists no more.
So we're going to pick up
the action on about page 30,
after this process has been
going on for a few months,
and they've translated
a lot of documents,
and they have a
database built up.
But they don't yet
fully understand
why magic disappeared.
NICOLE GALLAND: And
we're going to do it
as a dramatic rendition,
because so much of it
is just a conversation
between the two of them.
Normally, we have scripts
like Neal has there,
but I left mine
in the hotel room,
so I'm going to improvise
trying to remember
what I'm supposed to say where.
I think it'll be fine.
So it starts with Mel.
"There was never any
doubt as to the gist.
Some manner of cause
and effect relationship
existed between the rise
of scientific knowledge
and the decline of magic.
The two could not
comfortably co-exist.
To the extent that the database
could be cajoled into spitting
out actual numbers, it
was clear that magic
had declined gradually
but steadily starting
in the middle of the 1600s.
It was still holding
its own in the opening
decades of the 1800s but
plunged into a nosedive
during the 1830s.
From then through the 1840s,
magic declined precipitously.
As our store of documents, many
written by witches themselves,
grew to fill a phalanx of used
filing cabinets and gun safes
that Tristan scored
on Craigslist,
we were able to
track the decline
from year to year and
then from month to month.
These poor women expressed
shock at the dwindling
of their powers, in some cases,
mentioning specific spells
that had worked a few weeks
ago but no longer had effect.
As it turns out, in 1851, the
year in which I find myself
as I scribble these words, all
of the world's technologies
were brought together
for the Great Exhibition
at the newly constructed
magnificent Crystal
Palace in Hyde Park, London.
Tristan's hypothesis,
therefore, held
that this coming together,
this conscious concentration
of technological advancement
all in one point of spacetime
had dampened magic to the point,
where it fizzled out for good.
Like a doused fire,
it had no power
to rekindle itself
once extinguished.
The causal relationship between
the two eluded us for a time.
I suggested that magic's
flourishing required people
to believe in it, but Tristan
dismissed this mentality
as belonging more to children's
literature than to reality.
He was certain there was
a mechanical or physical
causality, that
there was something
about the technological world
view or technology itself
that somehow jammed the
frequencies magic used.
We both began to read whatever
we could about the Great
Exhibition in the hopes that
it might illuminate something.
You may notice that
I was exceeding
by far my responsibilities
as a translator.
Translating especially
of obscure texts
written in extinct
tongues often resembles
the solving of a riddle.
Here was a riddle to
put all others to shame.
Tristan's enthusiasm
was infectious,
and I could not
divest myself from it.
Having no other
responsibilities,
I became as preoccupied with
his project as he was himself.
Per Tristan's suggestion,
I took out stacks of books
from Widener Library.
Harvard had not figured
out yet that I'd quit.
These included tomes on
everything from heliography
to Queen Victoria's private
life to Baruch Spinoza's
sexual proclivities
to Frederick Bakewell
to the tempest prognosticator
to Strewhall numbers.
I would bring these
to Tristan, and we
would divide our time
between perusing them
and internet searches.
We soon knew more about the
Great Exhibition and its 13,000
odd exhibits than
Prince Albert ever did.
We knew more about its
showcase, the Crystal Palace,
than even Joseph
Paxton, the gardener
who designed the blessed thing.
We learned little
that was helpful.
However, one evening
in March, as I
sat on the consignment
store couch
I'd insisted on bringing
into spruce up the place,
and Tristan lolled on the rug
beside a low table with a beer,
each of us bleary-eyed
from reading,
I encountered a passage in
an obscure booklet entitled,
"Arresting and Alluring
Astronomical Anecdotes,"
published in 1897.
Here, I learned that while
the Great Exhibition of 1851
was in process--
it lasted for several months--
an event of relative interest
occurred elsewhere in Europe,
to be precise, in
Koenigsberg, Prussia.
For the first time in
history, a solar eclipse
was successfully photographed.
I read this statement aloud.
It set Tristan on
fire with excitement.
He had already suspected that
photography in particular
of all technological
developments
was the likeliest to have
somehow impeded magic.
Now somehow he was certain.
It took me a while to calm
him down to the point where
he could explain himself."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "I'll
be honest with you.
As a physicist, I'm a hack.
I majored in it,
yes, but I was never
employed in that capacity.
But if you cut me, I still
bleed physicist blood.
I'll go to my grave believing
that if magic existed,
there was a scientific
explanation for it."
NICOLE GALLAND: "That sounds
like a contradiction to me,
since our whole
working hypothesis is
that science broke it somehow."
NEAL STEPHENSON:
"Work with me here.
Have you ever heard of the
many worlds interpretation
of quantum mechanics?"
NICOLE GALLAND: "Only in
cocktail party discourse
that would make you roll your
eyes and heave deep sighs."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "Well, there
are certain experiments where
the results only make
sense if the system that's
being observed actually
exists in more than one state
until the moment when
the scientist makes
the observation."
NICOLE GALLAND: "Is
this Schroedinger's cat,
because even I have
heard of that?"
NEAL STEPHENSON: "Well,
that's the classic example.
It's just a thought
experiment, by the way.
No one ever actually did it."
NICOLE GALLAND: "That's good.
Peter would be all over them."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "Do
you know what it is?
You put a cat in a sealed box.
There's a device inside
of the box that's
capable of killing the cat by
breaking open a vial of poison
gas or something.
That device is triggered by
some random event generator like
a sample of some radioactive
material that either decays,
producing a bit of
radiation, or doesn't.
You close the lid.
The cat and the poison gas
and the radioactive sample
become a sealed system.
You cannot predict or
know what has happened."
NICOLE GALLAND: "You don't know
if the cat is alive or dead?"
NEAL STEPHENSON: "It's
not just that you don't.
You can't.
There's literally
no way of knowing.
Now in a classical
physics way of thinking,
it's either one or the other.
The cat is either
alive or dead for real.
You just don't
happen to know which.
But in a quantum
physics way of thinking,
the cat really is
both alive and dead.
It exists in two mutually
incompatible states
at the same time.
Not until you open the
lid and look inside
does the wave
function collapse."
NICOLE GALLAND: "Whoa, whoa.
You had me until the very end.
When did we start
talking about--
why did you call it?
A wave function?
And how does that
whatever it is collapse?"
NEAL STEPHENSON: "My bad.
It's just physicist lingo
for what I was saying.
If you were to express the
Schrodinger's cat experiment
mathematically, you'd
write down an equation
that's called a wave function.
That function has multiple
terms that are superimposed.
It's not just one thing."
NICOLE GALLAND:
"Multiple terms?"
NEAL STEPHENSON: "Yeah, a term
here means a fragment of math.
It is to an equation what
a phrase is to a sentence."
NICOLE GALLAND:
"So you're saying
there's one term for cat is
alive and another for cat
is dead.
Is that what you
mean in this usage?"
NEAL STEPHENSON:
"Yes, o linguist."
NICOLE GALLAND: "And when you
say they're superimposed?"
NEAL STEPHENSON:
"Mathematically, it just
means that they're sort
of added to each other
to make a combined
picture of the system."
NICOLE GALLAND: "Until it
collapses or whatever."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "Multiple
terms superimposed
is a quantum thing.
It's the essence of
quantum mechanics,
but there is this
interesting fact, which
is that that kind
of math only works,
it only provides an accurate
description of the system
until you open the
lid and look inside.
At that point, you see a live
cat or a dead cat, period.
It has become a
classical system"
NICOLE GALLAND: "Department
of deadly observations?
He rolled his eyes.
Anyway, that's what you mean
by the collapse of the wave
function."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "Yeah
it's just physicist
speak for the thing
that happens when
all of the superimposed
terms, the descriptions
of different possible
realities, resolve
into a single classical
outcome that our brains can
understand."
NICOLE GALLAND: "Our scientific
rational brains, you mean.
A look of mild satisfaction
came onto his face."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "Exactly."
NICOLE GALLAND: "But now we've
circled back to my theory."
NEAL STEPHENSON:
"Which theory is that?"
NICOLE GALLAND: "The
one that belongs
more to children's
literature than to reality.
Remember?"
NEAL STEPHENSON: "Oh, yeah.
People have to
believe in magic."
NICOLE GALLAND: "Yes."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "That's
not exactly what I'm saying.
Yes, human consciousness is
in the loop, but hear me out.
If you buy the many worlds
interpretation of quantum
mechanics, it means that all
possible outcomes are really
happening somewhere."
NICOLE GALLAND: "There's
one world with a live cat
and another with a dead cat."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "Exactly.
No kidding.
Complete, fully independent
realities that are the same,
except that in one of them, the
cat's dead, and in the other,
it's alive.
In the quantum
superposition, that just
means that the
scientist standing there
with his hand on the lid of the
box is at a fork in the road.
Both paths, both
worlds are open to him.
He could shunt into
one or the other.
And when he hauls the lid
open, the decision gets made.
He's now in one
world or the other,
and there's no going back."
NICOLE GALLAND: "'OK,' I said,
not in the sense of I agree
with you, but in the sense
of I am paying attention."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "The
scientist can't control
which path he or she takes."
NICOLE GALLAND: "I saw
that he was trolling me,
waiting for me to
pick up the bait.
No, it was more than that.
He wanted me to
mention a possibility
that he could think about but
never say out loud, because he
was all Mr. Science.
So I did.
Let's switch it up a
little, then, I said,
and swap out the white lab
coat and the clipboard for--
I don't know-- a pointy
black hat and a broom,
and lose a pronoun, if she
did somehow have the ability
to choose which
world she was going
to be shunted to when she opened
the lid, if she could control
the outcome."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "It
would look like magic."
NICOLE GALLAND: "What
do you mean look like?
It would be magic."
NEAL STEPHENSON:
"Just saying that it's
about choosing possible
outcomes that already exist,
slipstreaming between closely
related alternate realities
as opposed to bringing those
realities into existence."
NICOLE GALLAND: "But
that's a distinction
without a difference."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "As far as
normal observers are concerned,
people who haven't studied
quantum physics, sure."
NICOLE GALLAND: "Put
it however you like.
A witch may summon
the desired effect
from a parallel/simultaneous
reality.
Thus, the historical
references of witches' magic
as summoning-- that
is quite literally
what they were doing."
NEAL STEPHENSON:
"My hypothesis."
NICOLE GALLAND: "Tristan
said, pronouncing the word
with exaggerated care, since
he had a few beers in him."
NEAL STEPHENSON:
"Is that photography
disables this summoning,
as you called it.
Photography breaks
magic by embalming
a specific moment, one
version of reality,
into a recorded image.
Once that moment is
so recorded, then
all other possible
versions of that moment
are excluded from the world
that contains that photograph."
NICOLE GALLAND: "I get it.
There's no wiggle room left in
which to function magically.
He nodded.
He seemed relieved to have
got all of this off his chest
and that I hadn't laughed
him out of the room.
'You've been thinking about
this for a while,' I said.
He nodded.
But it wasn't until we
saw the daguerreotype
of the solar eclipse
that the penny dropped."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "That's right."
NICOLE GALLAND: "That was
only about the bazillionth
daguerreotype ever made.
People had been taking
photographs for 16 years
by that point.
What's so special
about that one?"
NEAL STEPHENSON:
"The scope of it,
I think, the number of
minds and worlds affected.
If I'm Louis Daguerre screwing
around in my lab in Paris,
taking pictures of
whatever's handy,
then I'd collapse
the waveform, yes,
but only in as much as
it encompasses my brain
and a few little
objects in my lab.
If I showed the daguerreotype
to my wife or my friend,
then the effect spreads
to them as well,
and we can guess that witches
who live in the neighborhood
might sense a dampening
of their magical abilities
without understanding why.
But the total eclipse of
the sun on July 28, 1851,
was probably witnessed
by more human beings
than any other event in
the history of the world up
to that point."
NICOLE GALLAND: "Of course.
Everyone in Europe
could see it."
NEAL STEPHENSON:
"Just by looking up
into the sky, hundreds of
millions of people, Mel.
That event captured more
eyeballs at the same moment
than any Beyonce
video on YouTube,
and to the extent that
it was frozen and bombed
on a daguerreotype, well--"
NICOLE GALLAND: "If
previous uses of photography
had dampened magic, then this
was like dumping the Atlantic
Ocean on it."
NEAL STEPHENSON:
"When the shutter
opened to capture that first
perfect image of the eclipse,
magic ceased to function
across all human societies."
NICOLE GALLAND: "We back checked
the dates of all documents
from 1851.
Indeed, there were three from
the first half of the year, two
English, one Italian.
There was a fragment of one
in late July, Hungarian.
There were none after July 28th,
the date of the eclipse, none."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "That said."
NICOLE GALLAND: "Muttered
Tristan, preoccupied,
getting to his feet.
He rested his hands on his
desk and stared absently
at the wall.
'Yes,' I said.
I felt deflated.
Although he'd never
told me why D.O.D.O. was
so interested in
understanding magic,
common sense screamed
it was because they
wanted to be able to do it.
Department of Doing the Occult?
Which clearly
could never happen.
There's no getting
rid of photography,
so there's no
bringing magic back.
Tristan froze, and
after a beat, jerked
his head in my direction."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "You're right.
That's it.
Where there is no photography,
there could still be magic."
NICOLE GALLAND: "That's
not quite what I said.
He began to pace the office.
We had made it somewhat
larger by knocking out
walls that separated it
from adjoining spaces,
but this still
required following
a figure 8-ish path between
piles of books, artifacts,
freestanding gun
safes to be recycled,
beer bottles, and
still unexplained high
tech military gear."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "How do
we get rid of photography?"
NICOLE GALLAND: "We cannot
get rid of photography."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "No,
it's definitely possible.
I just have to figure
out how it's done."
NICOLE GALLAND: "What do
you mean how it's done?"
NEAL STEPHENSON: "I'm
not seeing something.
What am I missing?"
NICOLE GALLAND: "You're
missing the part where
photography became
ubiquitous, and all magic
went away forever.
He turned to look at me, his
eyes focused now and bright."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "No,
it's not a lost cause."
NICOLE GALLAND: "That
was not the tone
of hypothesis or theory.
That was the tone of
either faith or knowledge.
I felt a shiver
run down my spine.
I realized there are a lot
of things you can't tell me,
but whatever it
specifically is you're not
telling me at this precise
moment, fucking tell me.
Otherwise, I'm useless.
His gaze went fuzzy
again as he engaged
in some brief mental soliloquy.
Then he nodded."
NEAL STEPHENSON: "I
can't tell you much.
But I can tell you that
we know it's possible."
NICOLE GALLAND: "We?"
NEAL STEPHENSON: "D.O.D.O.
There's evidence.
That's all I can say."
NICOLE GALLAND: OK.
NEAL STEPHENSON: So that's
the end of the reading.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
So that's kind of the
setup for the story.
That's all the first 30 or so--
NICOLE GALLAND: And then
there's still all that.
NEAL STEPHENSON: Yeah.
Yeah.
So this is the point where
we normally jump over
to question and answer time.
So I believe we have some
kind of bouncing cube
that is going to be
used to facilitate that.
Thanks for turning
up the lights.
Well, it is quite a sort
of empty band in the middle
of the room there.
We've definitely got
back of the bus people--
NICOLE GALLAND: If this
was a folk concert,
we would encourage you all
to move down to the front.
NEAL STEPHENSON: Fortunately,
it's not a folk--
yeah.
SPEAKER: So we have
this throwable mic,
which you've probably
seen if you've
been to any of these events
in the last month or so.
So does anyone have a question?
NICOLE GALLAND: That's so cool.
AUDIENCE: So now
I know, I guess,
why Google sold off
our satellite business.
[INAUDIBLE] next, I guess.
So how do you guys collaborate
on a book like this?
Did you work together, or
did you do it remotely?
Did you do a chapter at a time?
NEAL STEPHENSON:
So we keep saying
that we need to fabricate a
bunch of stories about all
the drama and tension
that existed and made it
such a thrill-charged
collaboration.
But it was pretty
calm, professional.
There was the idea, which came
from an idea I came up with,
and we developed it
to a certain point,
where we kind of knew
who the characters were.
We had a sense of what
kind of people they were
and the overall
arc of the story.
And then Nikki kind of would
break trail, for the most part.
NICOLE GALLAND: I would
play around with it,
and then when I felt like I had
gotten it as far as I could,
I'd pass it back to Neal.
Neal would tweak it.
There were some
things, especially
like the section
you just read, which
there's a lot of
quantum theory there,
which Neal's a little more
comfortable than I am.
So he broke ground on
those parts of that
and then would send it to me.
So it really was-- it
was very intuitive.
It just seemed very
obvious to both of us
who was better prepared in
terms of schedule and expertise
or even just the kind of
voice we were creating.
So whoever it made sense
to start would start,
and then the other
person would do pick up.
So we both ended up--
our fingerprints are all
over the whole thing,
both of our fingerprints.
But it was really--
it was very intuitive.
Actually, that's a lie.
He kept me locked
in his basement
and fed me chocolate whenever
I finished a chapter.
NEAL STEPHENSON: It's
an epistolary book,
so it's written as a series of
documents that were allegedly
extracted from an
archive that was
stolen from this organization.
So what you've been hearing
is a little bit anomalous
in that it's an extended
narrative written by one voice.
But there's big sections
of the book that
are in the form of text message
exchanges or transcripts
or email threads or Slack
messages or PowerPoint
presentations.
Kind of the whole bureaucratic
communication apparatus
ends up making an
appearance in this book.
AUDIENCE: Hello?
Oh.
Besides the how, why?
Why?
What made the two
of you think this
was a book that really needed
somebody else's voice, somebody
else's input?
NEAL STEPHENSON: Well, we
worked together previously
on another big collaborative
project called "The Mongoliad,"
so we kind of had a
sense that it could work.
And this just--
I mean the original idea kind
of came to me as I said--
as I started thinking
about what would
be entailed in actually
making it into a novel.
And it just seemed to me like a
completely obvious opportunity
to collaborate with Nikki
again, since her metier is
writing well-researched
historical novels.
NICOLE GALLAND: He twisted
my arm, and I said yes.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So I don't want
to give any spoilers,
but I'm seeing some relationship
to "Anathem" in this.
I won't say what.
Without giving it
away, should we
be keeping our eye open
for any Easter eggs?
NEAL STEPHENSON: No,
there's none of that stuff.
But you're correct
about the connection.
So when I was
working on "Anathem,"
I got interested in this whole
many worlds interpretation
of quantum mechanics
and learned that there's
a branch of metaphysics,
so there are still
people who do metaphysics
for a living, it turns out.
And some of them think
about alternate worlds
or possible worlds
in a very serious way
like with logical formalism,
and so it's a thing.
And it stuck with
me a little bit,
and so I think you're right in
seeing that kind of connection.
But there's not the
other kind of connection
that you're thinking of.
NICOLE GALLAND: I
have a little anecdote
I can add to that, which
is the first two times--
you're not the first person
that's pointed that out--
but the first two times,
someone in the audience
asked Neal about that, like
it hadn't occurred to him.
It's occurred to him
now, because he's been
reminded of it enough times.
NEAL STEPHENSON: Oh, good.
It finally went airborne.
Just--
AUDIENCE: Keeping to
the theme of connections
on to earlier books,
any chance Enoch Root
is walking around
in 1851 in London?
And if not, any chance
we'll get the final third
of "Cryptonomicon?"
NEAL STEPHENSON: Nope.
I mean it is not connected
to my other books.
There's no Enoch
Root in this one.
And no, it's a standalone.
I mean there may be--
there already are
other spin-outs of this book.
So we struck up a relationship
with a startup called Bound.
It's getbound.io, which they're
making an app for reading,
for enjoying fiction either by
reading it or listening to it.
And they're sort of coming
out of a gaming background.
So I think they were
originally thinking
of adding narrative
content to game worlds,
but it was a really good fit
for what we wanted to do.
And so they launched on Tuesday.
They're on the App Store.
I don't know if they've
got an Android app.
Anyway, the point is that there
are some other writers who've
been playing in this world
already during the last year
or so, and so Bound is going
to be episodically releasing
some of their work, which
purports to be other leaked
material from the same archive.
But it's different characters
and different stories.
NICOLE GALLAND: Different
narratives, yeah.
NEAL STEPHENSON:
But no Enoch Root.
NICOLE GALLAND: And also
different documents.
Are the bureaucratic
documents going into Bound's--
NEAL STEPHENSON: Yeah, the
sexual harassment policy is up,
I think.
A bunch of the sort of
bureaucratic type things are.
NICOLE GALLAND: So
I did some of that,
and then we had six
other writers contribute.
So there's a whole lot of--
literally a lot of different
voices involved in that one.
And it's expanding
gradually through time.
NEAL STEPHENSON:
I'll heave it back.
Someone will catch it.
No?
No, I guess if they were--
AUDIENCE: Stylistically,
how did you
choose to do
bureaucratic documents?
That's not--
NEAL STEPHENSON: Really boring.
AUDIENCE: --a
traditional novel style.
NEAL STEPHENSON:
Well, you've got to--
I mean so as I
think you can sense,
the overall tone of this
book is more lighthearted
satirical fun--
NICOLE GALLAND: Than,
say, "Seveneves."
NEAL STEPHENSON: Right, yeah.
So it's an opportunity to kind
of make fun of that stuff.
So hopefully, in those
parts of the document that
are like PowerPoint
presentations,
they're sufficiently
over the top
that they'll actually
be enjoyable to read.
NICOLE GALLAND: Neal did a
lot of the original drafts
of those, and when I got them,
I was laughing out loud, which
normally doesn't happen
when I'm reading PowerPoint
presentations.
NEAL STEPHENSON:
In front of you.
NICOLE GALLAND: Throw
that man a cube.
AUDIENCE: So I think you
tried something similar
with "Seveneves,"
where "Seveneves"
was sort of an anchor in
a universe around which
ancillary projects
were scattered.
Is that working out well?
You're doing the same thing
again, so I assume so.
NEAL STEPHENSON:
I'm trying to think
of the ancillary
"Seveneves" projects.
I mean I'm always
thinking about it.
It seems like something
that ought to work.
And I feel like I'm in a good,
relatively privileged position
to be able to try to make
that kind of thing work.
But then it always turns
out to be really hard,
and writing novels and
getting them published
turns out to be really easy.
So in the case of "Seveneves,"
there is a film adaptation
under way, and that
seems to be moving along
in a promising way.
But what tends to happen is
that if something like that
gets going, it has a
suppressing effect on everything
else, because why bother
trying to work on anything
else like a game
or what have you
if there's a
possibility that a movie
project is going to happen?
So it causes everything
else to be sort of abandoned
or put on hold while you wait
for the next thing to move.
In the case of the
Bound collaboration,
so far, that's not happening,
because the timing just
happened to work out really
well that they had a startup.
They wanted to launch their
app at exactly the same time
as the book was going to launch.
And so it's out there.
We'll see how it develops.
NICOLE GALLAND: Can you just
like throw it up in the air
so we can have--
NEAL STEPHENSON: Yeah.
We were told there was
going to be a flying cube.
OK.
Well.
NICOLE GALLAND: Thank you.
NEAL STEPHENSON: Yeah, thanks.
AUDIENCE: So what's
the best book
you've read in the last year
that's not one of your own?
NEAL STEPHENSON: The last year.
NICOLE GALLAND: Oh, this
is one of those deer
in headlight questions.
AUDIENCE: I mean, whatever.
A book that you read in the
last year that you really liked.
Doesn't have to be the best.
NEAL STEPHENSON: No, it's
just this comes up every time,
and every time, we
say we really should
have a prepped answer for this.
And then--
AUDIENCE: Better than
watching [INAUDIBLE]
NEAL STEPHENSON: It's terrible,
because it's an opportunity
to support somebody else's work.
And-- oh, see, I
finally thought of one.
Annalee Newitz has
one that's coming out.
I can't remember
the title of it.
That's terrible.
But if only there was
some kind of search engine
that could find this.
NICOLE GALLAND: In your brain?
NEAL STEPHENSON: Yeah.
NICOLE GALLAND: There will be.
NEAL STEPHENSON: So Newitz,
N-E-W-I-T-Z, first name,
Annalee, A-N-N-A-L-E-E.
And I think it's just out,
so so that's worth checking out.
It's her first book, so
should be easy to find on Bing
or whatever.
NICOLE GALLAND: I know what
the most interesting thing I've
read in the last year
is, but I guarantee you
it will not be of
interest to any of you.
So it's the town
report for the Town
of West Tisbury,
Massachusetts, which
is research for a project
I'm working on now.
And it's really like--
AUDIENCE: OK, so why was
that so interesting then?
NICOLE GALLAND: Sorry, what?
AUDIENCE: Why was that the most
interesting thing you read?
NICOLE GALLAND: Because it--
because it fed research
that I was trying to do,
and it forced me--
I grew up in the
town of West Tisbury,
and it forced me to step back
and look at my own microcosm
as a thing that could be studied
as opposed to just a place
to live in.
But it made me bend
my brain in a new way.
But A, I'm almost
the only person
that it would have
that effect on.
And you guys have probably never
even heard of West Tisbury, so.
AUDIENCE: What year
is the report from?
NEAL STEPHENSON: They're
going to go get it.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Is that like
a recent thing or?
NICOLE GALLAND: Yeah, it's 2016.
It's the town report for the
town of West Tisbury, 2016.
NEAL STEPHENSON: How long is it?
NICOLE GALLAND: It's about--
it's about that thick.
NEAL STEPHENSON: Wow.
NICOLE GALLAND: It's like
one Neal Stephenson chapter.
NEAL STEPHENSON: So there's
another interesting thing
that's happened.
It's not-- I don't think it
was published in the last year,
but Matt Ruff, R-U-F-F, has a
really interesting book called
"Lovecraft Country," which is
hard to encapsulate the story.
But it's a brilliant,
weird idea.
And just-- it just was
announced a couple of weeks
ago that it's going to
be a television series.
So that's worth checking out.
You can say that you read
the book before it was on TV.
AUDIENCE: Is the Annalee
Newitz book, "Autonomous?"
NEAL STEPHENSON:
That sounds right.
Part of my problem is that
they send these things to me
to blurb, and sometimes
they have different titles.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
NEAL STEPHENSON:
So like I blurbed--
that's another good one--
Cory Doctorow's book, which
is now called "Walkaway."
When I blurbed it, it
was called, "Utopia."
So.
And there's one coming
out in September
by Joe Brassey, who's one of
the other "Mongoliad" writers
called "Skyfarer," which is just
a great, fun adventure sci-fi
fantasy novel, so.
NICOLE GALLAND:
You've been better
at reading new stuff than me.
I'm like in hermit
mode at the moment.
NEAL STEPHENSON: Nice.
AUDIENCE: That made me think.
What genres do you both read
for both inspiration and fun?
NICOLE GALLAND: I
read a huge range.
When I'm working on a story
with a particular tone,
I often try to stay
close to other books that
are in that tone just
so that my inner voice--
I tend to walk around thinking
in the voice of whatever I'm
reading.
So I try to keep the
voice fairly consistent
when I'm in a certain
part of my process.
But then when I'm not, I like to
go as far afield as I possibly
can.
So historical-- I love
historical fiction.
I like some sci-fi and fantasy.
I don't gobble it up
in quite the same way.
I like contemporary
literary fiction
and contemporary
commercial fiction,
and I love kids' books.
I just like being reminded
of being in that headspace.
NEAL STEPHENSON: I
read a lot of history.
Surprise, surprise.
And some books about science.
Oh, see, now it's coming to me.
"Arrival of the Fittest"
by Andreas Wagner--
really interesting
book about science.
And it's about
the problem with--
how does evolution actually
work on a combinatorial level?
Just randomly
shuffling amino acids
around doesn't seem like
it would get you anywhere,
if you look at all of the
combinations that would fail.
So he's coming at--
he's at the Santa Fe Institute.
He's done all kinds of really
interesting computational work
in this area and has got
a really readable book
out on that topic that was
pretty amazing to read.
NICOLE GALLAND: Cool.
I read a lot of plays.
I completely forgot that,
because my background
is in theater,
and I can't really
divorce myself from that.
That's-- yeah.
NEAL STEPHENSON: Anyone else?
Whoops.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NEAL STEPHENSON: Oh, OK.
Yeah.
Thank you.
NICOLE GALLAND: Taking
one for the team.
NEAL STEPHENSON: I want
to see a perfect spiral.
NICOLE GALLAND: Yeah, all right.
NEAL STEPHENSON:
Now we're talking.
AUDIENCE: All right, so
this was not the first book
either of you've written.
I assume it won't be the
last either of you write.
I'm just curious, what are
you looking forward to trying
differently next time, perhaps?
NEAL STEPHENSON: What are
our next book projects?
AUDIENCE: Just not necessarily
what the plot is, but just
what are you going to try
doing differently as you
embark on your next projects?
NICOLE GALLAND: I'm a
little superstitious
about talking about stuff
that hasn't been birthed yet.
AUDIENCE: OK.
NEAL STEPHENSON: Yeah,
I'm the same way,
so I resort to generalities.
So both of us are
working on solo books,
so although we had a
great time collaborating,
that's an unnatural
state of affairs,
and we're both
reverting to form.
So I'm working on one that is--
technically, you could call
it a follow-on to "Reamde,"
but it's so different
from "Reamde"
that it's just going
to confuse everybody
if I describe it that way.
So back to more of a
contemporary near term sci-fi
kind of sensibility.
NICOLE GALLAND: I'm
writing something
that requires me to read the
West Tisbury Town Report.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm wondering,
how much influence
do you have over the audiobook
versions of your works?
Do you work with the
narrators, or is this just--
sometimes I wonder if it's this
third party's interpretation
of the work that I'm
actually getting.
NICOLE GALLAND: Normally, it is
a third party interpretation.
In fact, for "Stepdog,"
a friend of mine who's
in the industry scolded
me that I was sort
of trying to indirectly
get to the actor,
because we happened to
know him a little bit.
But in this particular
case, that same person
is now very happy
with me, because I
got her the role of Mel, the
voice that I was just reading.
She is my college roommate, who
studied linguistics at Harvard,
and she is now playing
the voice of a person that
studied linguistics at Harvard.
She's a voiceover artist.
I mean I didn't just
pluck her out of nowhere.
So I got to have control over
that, which was really fun.
And in this particular
case, there's
a few funky things
about how Mel writes.
She's writing, as she says, with
a dip pen in Victorian England.
So what I did not
include is that there's
a few places where as she's
writing, she drops an F bomb
or says something that's
very anachronistic.
And then she crosses
it out, and then puts
something that's more Victorian,
because she is clearly
going to be stuck there
for the rest of her life.
So she's trying to make
herself think like a Victorian.
And so she's correcting
herself, and in the audio book,
the way that they did that was
[INAUDIBLE] would start to say,
"fu--" and then she'd
cut herself off,
and then they added
a little sound bite
that was the sound of a
pen scratching out a word.
So that was-- she
came up with what
she was going to do
by talking to me,
and then once they heard her,
they added the scratchy thing.
NEAL STEPHENSON: Nice, nice.
Yeah.
No, it's gotten
really interesting,
because it blew up into
such a big important market
that a lot of smart
people are getting engaged
and thinking about how to
make the process better.
And so it's changed
my style a little bit,
because I used to put more
diagrams and things that you
can't read out loud into books.
And now I don't do that.
Like footnotes, for
example, are problematic.
Like some actors have like their
special footnote tone of voice
that they'll go into
to sort of give you
a cue that this is a footnote.
But it's still really
awkward in audio.
And I just heard that--
this might be
interesting to you--
I can't remember if it's
Brilliance or Audible,
but one of the big
audio book companies
is trying to reach
out to playwrights
and produce more
original content that
would be more dramatic.
NICOLE GALLAND: Well,
that's interesting.
NEAL STEPHENSON: As
opposed to just reading
a prose book that's
actually set up
like what we used
to call a radio play
and what is now
called an audio drama.
So it's a huge market,
because there's
all these people, like long haul
truck drivers or assembly line
workers, who listen
to audio books
like eight, 10, 12 hours a day.
And so they have an insatiable
demand for this stuff.
And so all kinds of
really interesting things
are going on in that space,
and it's a cool space to be in.
NICOLE GALLAND: You
just reminded me
of something that's only
tangentially related,
historically.
In Cuba, the cigar rollers used
to have professional readers
brought over from Europe to
read them Tolstoy and things
like that.
So it's a grand old tradition.
I'm glad it's continuing.
NEAL STEPHENSON: Yeah,
the Monte Cristo cigar,
which is one of the
best, most famous cigars,
was named that,
because in that room,
the favorite book of
those cigar rollers
was "The Count of Monte Cristo."
Yeah.
Anyone?
OK, all right.
AUDIENCE: So I assume you
guys enjoy writing books,
but it's also your job.
So how does that
kind of play out?
Is there conflict
at any time in terms
of like when it ceases
to be enjoyable,
and it becomes just a job?
NICOLE GALLAND: I've
had just a jobs,
and writing is never just a job.
It's a lot of work sometimes.
Sometimes it's really fun.
When I wrote my first
novel, "The Fool's Tale,"
at a certain point, I went
from having writer's block
to being completely obsessed.
And I was writing 17 hours
a day and couldn't stop.
Like the discipline
was to stop doing it
and do things like eat breakfast
or take a shower or sleep.
And then there's other times
that it's like pulling teeth,
but neither of
those two extremes
are how I've ever felt
about anything that's
like a job, where you show
up somewhere and have a boss
and do your job,
and then go home.
So for me personally,
it's its own thing.
And even though it varies,
all of its various faces
are set apart from
any other kind of work
that I ever did before it.
You have a different answer,
because you have a different--
NEAL STEPHENSON: Yeah, I
figured out a long time ago
that it's best if I
get up in the morning,
write for a couple of hours,
maybe three hours max,
and then stop, and do something
else for the rest of the day.
And by something else, I mean
something that's totally not
writing, something like doing
geeky things or building
things, because there's a lot
that happens as a background
process.
And you've got to
allow that to happen,
or I have to allow
that to happen,
because if I don't, then
when I get up the next day
and go back to writing,
I don't have anything.
So I just long ago
figured out I had
to let the mysterious
background process do its thing.
And then even doing two,
even one hour of work a day
generates enough material
to produce a book in a year,
two years easy.
So it's not a--
it doesn't slow things
down to take that kind
of measured paced approach.
But there is this weird
thing that it's like--
you know, we used to
call it dieseling,
where you shut your
car off, but the engine
keeps running for
a little while.
That happens to me.
So when I stop, I have to
carry my phone around with me
and do voice memos
for about 15 minutes,
because I'll get like
lines of dialogue or ideas
that are kind of
dieseling in my head.
It's usually good stuff, and
so I'll make a record of those.
And then that's where
I start the next day.
So.
SPEAKER: So we're
almost out of time,
so if anyone has
the last question.
AUDIENCE: If I can figure
out how to phrase it.
This one's
specifically for Neal.
You've written a lot of
pretty well-known books
and have a lot of fans.
And I'm wondering out
of all those books,
which ones do you think has
produced the most rabid fans?
NEAL STEPHENSON:
The most rabid fans?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you know,
which books are most--
I don't want to say
inspiring, but--
NEAL STEPHENSON: There's
different kinds of rabid fans.
There's like a
taxonomy of rabid fans.
So I think it seems to me
that among female readers,
"Diamond Age" and
"Snow Crash" are
both super popular, maybe
"Diamond Age" a little more so.
And then "Cryptonomicon"
is really popular.
It's just it's always a
different rabid fan kind of.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NEAL STEPHENSON: Yeah.
Yeah, and so for example, when
I published "Quicksilver,"
which is my first kind of
straight up historical novel,
I went.
I did a tour in the UK for that,
and some guy approached me,
a silver-haired guy
walked up and said hello.
And he had become
a fan of that book,
but he had no idea I had
written anything else.
So that's just kind of
how that market works
for whatever reason.
SPEAKER: We have
a couple minutes,
so I'm going to ask
a follow-up to that,
which is, Nicole,
you're mostly known
for writing historical fiction.
So this is a little
out of genre.
Do you find that a lot of your
fans are excited for this book
or excited for you to do more
stuff like this that's kind
of comedic or more
sci-fi-ey, or--
NICOLE GALLAND: I think so.
Something that I've been
trying to come to terms with
is the fact that I think
I'm a little funnier than I
think I am.
I don't think of myself
as trying to write funny,
but that seems to be a lot of
the feedback that I'm getting
is that's part of what
people like about my writing.
This is not as out of genre as
my last book, which I think we
were talking about this before.
I wrote one contemporary
romantic comedy.
It's the last book that I
wrote, and this actually
feels like a return to form,
because for instance, we
needed medieval warfare
for a section of this book.
And so we chose
the Fourth Crusade,
because I wrote a
novel called "Crossed:
A Tale of the Fourth Crusade."
So we were drawing--
I actually got to return to a
lot of my stuff in doing this.
"Stepdog" was the
one that just--
even my editor said, well,
that came out of nowhere.
So this was sort of like
a fun, playful return
to familiar
material, but getting
to do it in a whole new way.
And that was delightful.
I love trying new things,
and this was just delightful.
SPEAKER: Do you have you
Easter egg characters
from your previous
Fourth Crusade book?
NICOLE GALLAND:
I don't think so.
If I do, they're buried so
deeply that I didn't even
mention it to Neal.
Now I'm starting to feel
like maybe there's some,
but I've even buried
it from myself.
NEAL STEPHENSON: You've probably
referred to important figures
like the emperor, whatever,
who was mentioned.
NICOLE GALLAND: Yeah, so
there's historical Easter
eggs, so to speak, but not--
no.
No, I don't do that.
But maybe I should.
I shall start.
SPEAKER: OK, I think
we're out of time.
So thanks for coming, everybody.
And Neal and Nicole
already signed a bunch
of the books that are for sale.
I may have forgotten to mention
that books are for sale,
so please talk to
a rep at the back.
And they're going to
be here for a couple
minutes if you want to say hi.
NEAL STEPHENSON:
Thanks for having us.
NICOLE GALLAND: Thanks
for having us, yeah.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]